oh
yay
ready for the annual New Year's Day dip
Scarborough's South Beach had a
cornucopia of wildlife jellyfish
Penguins parrots lobsters even a unicorn
but no walrus
that's because the Resort's latest
celebrity Thor has gone after resting up
he's headed off to continue what's being
a lengthy and well-documented tour of
Europe
Thor left his Arctic Homeland and was
first spotted in Zealand in the
Netherlands before swimming past Belgium
and into France he stopped over in the
app and was then seen in poulier before
nipping across the channel to cowshot in
Hampshire 19 days later he popped up in
Scarborough now he's off again
presumably and hopefully heading north
so he's here for about 18 hours or so
yeah he came in we think about Harper's
Channel Friday night and then was here
till about half past four yesterday
afternoon so about 18 hours
thankfully there were no welfare
concerns for Thor he might be far from
home but otherwise he seems to be
perfectly healthy he's off course yeah
for some reason he's decided to leave
the Arctic go for wonder you're
wondering Wellness for a better word and
now he's heading back North in the right
direction so probably the mistake he
made was leaving the Arctic in the first
place wherever he actually was going
south on hoped and are we on
reorientating back North up to where he
he belongs his visit certainly caused a
splash for those lucky enough to see him
what was he like did he look happy he
looked very happy very relaxed and
enjoying the uh the stardom I believe
so for the new year Dippers no need to
share the water now the only thing that
makes me swim faster I think if they
were chasing me what a size that was did
you see the walrus yeah what was he
doing snoring you know the first was
Scarborough and I believe her first for
Yorkshire as well so we're very proud
that he chose Scarborough to have enough
it's the first time in living memory
that Scarborough has hosted a tusky
tourist like Thor even if it wasn't for
long as much as the good Focus
Scarborough might have liked to have
seen Thor hang around for a little bit
longer it turns out he was one of those
visitors known in the resort as a
comfort it's just Comfort day
Scarborough canceled its New Year's
firework display to prevent any distress
to its rare visitor but he was gone well
before midnight slipping into the water
at about 4 30 on New Year's Eve to
continue his Grand Tour
Fraser Maude Sky News Scarborough